et puis enfin dans les sujets du moment
il y a la question ukrainienne alors là
aussi je vrais être très clair parce que
bon l'Ukraine est en guerre l'Europe
doit apporter son concours à un peuple
qui se bat pour sa liberté ses
frontières son modèle très bien bon donc
il y a pas de malentendu mais l'Ukraine
est un grand pays agricole c'est à peu
près un/4 de l'Europe agricole dans le
moment dans lequel on est euh qu'on
vienne en aide aux Ukrainiens je pense
que tout le monde peut le comprendre
mais ça n'empêche pas de poser la
question agricole je vous donne quelques
exemples il est rentré il rentrait
d'habitude avant le conflit 20000 tonnes
de sucre ukrainien en Europe il en est
rentré l'année dernière près de 700000
tonnes je pense que tout le monde
comprend qu'à un moment en terme de
déstabilisation des marchés il y a un
problème bon qu'est-ce qu'on dit nous on
dit que il faut qu'on trouve à partir de
de clause de sauvegarde la possibilité
de faire rentrer quelques volumes parce
que après en Fran ch de droit de Douine
parce qu'après tout c'est pas c'est pas
choquant qu'on qu'on continue commercer
mais que le reste on regarde comment
éventuellement on peut faire des
corridors pourexorter parce qu'on
comprend bien que les ports de la mer
Noire sont pas aussi disponibles mais ce
sujet il faut l'adresser et si vous
posez la question un agriculteur
polonais ou roumain il sera encore plus
déterminé que ce que je viens de de vous
dire donc le sujet c'est pas de tomber
dans les agriculteurs ne pensent qu'à
eux veulent pas se soucier de l'Ukraine
il y a une réalité de de marché voilà
donc il faut quand même qu'on la regarde
parce que ça se traduit derrière par des
fermetures de de de de de d'outil sur
tout le territoire national voilà quand
vous avez une sucrerie et que vous êtes
face à ce sujet de compétition c'est
c'est un problème et et et on pourrait
le le multiplier donc voilà ce sujet
c'est pas pour dire encore une fois
l'Europe est une île on veut rien faire
mais on a besoin de de l'